in their private yes episode and I help
you sir well I hope so my name is Scott
Shelby I'm a private detective when my
boy mother disappeared yes I received a
letter with a locker ticket inside
inside the locker I found this box
I'm agent Nam and Jamie from the FBI
I went by your office this morning they
told me verify based on what we've seen
looks like the work of you ah yes hell
are you I'm so cool how's it goin Bret
my name the killer is the iPad age
between 30 and 45 iMac doesn't act on
impulse but plans his crimes in a very
meticulous fast Chiklis he doesn't have
anything personal against the victims
that's why it covers her faces with mud
to make them enough why does he kill
them if he doesn't have anything against
them he may have other reasons for him
the more of an image assemble that's
probably why it gives him an origami
figure and an orchid as gifts to
apologize what he's done oh that's the
very interesting and where does all that
get us yeah all right I'm gonna be
pissed at him because I hate him profile
of the killer and helps us understand
the person we're looking for might be
useful if it was done earlier in this
investigation exactly
continue Jaden the rainfall one detail
attracted my attention the interval
between the time when a victim
disappears in the time when the body is
found ranges from three to five days but
the rainfall is always at six inches
give or take 10% what on earth does that
mean see John so air drain while dying
water the killer kills only in the fall
when there was plenty of rain it could
be that he puts them in some sort of
well or tank that is open to the skies
and that fills up a brain water the more
it rains the less time the victim
to live we don't have a Geo profiling
and it's gonna keep changing the image
then I studied the geographic location
of the murders generally I did see how
users first murder near to where he
lives so he has a safe place to flee to
if any complications arise the more
confident he becomes the further he
roams from his base by analyzing the
locations where the victims disappeared
I was able to isolate a zone where the
killer might live and what size is this
zone sizes your mama's [ __ ] for the
moment about 10 square mile oh great
must be ten thousand people live in that
sword area you get a question on one by
one I'm gonna be pissed again it may not
give us the address of the killer but at
least did someone to go on Blake if
you've got a better plan I'm willing to
listen don't be shy I'm all ears
that's right Blake so what's next there
are two suspects who psychological
profile might fit and can be connected
to the comfort zone I'd like to question
them ah damn it we're wasting our time
with this [ __ ] the killers out there
somewhere we got to get off our asses
and find them go for him
Blake I've got just about enough of your
[ __ ] you've been chasing this guy for
what two years
what are you caught huh nothing
abso-fucking-lutely nothing we think it
could do better [ __ ] job than my ad
holla G degree in your great glasses hey
let me tell you daddy's first in my
class I mean zip when it comes to
getting out there you're just a [ __ ]
bureaucrat I'm gonna calm down huh I
came here to find a killer and then it's
exactly what I'm gonna do with or
without your assets a nice Jesus Christ
you said it took six inches of rainfall
before the victim died
how much time do we have left the
weather forecasts are right listen Sammy
oh that's soon oh I are who are we now
are we investigating [ __ ] love him
not in a gay way why I did not a nice a
cool character DSP is not as cool as I
want him to be but hey what can you do
about it
no answer
who wastes our time coming here
maybe we should have a little look
inside anyway there's nobody home we
just opened the door silly pants
there is no that's convenient I'm not
sure that's entirely legal
call the cop that's funny
oh yeah this guy's the killer we found
the killer
no he's just looks like Nathaniel
Williams is a pretty religious guy what
makes you say that
to god-fearing idiot waiting for the end
of the world how the hell do I question
him a few months oh look there's
Melody's causing a disturbance in the
park
it was ranting and raving said he heard
voices had this idea in its nice head
that cousin Antichrist I'd come to earth
to persecute all I think is about right
who medication we found some clues
I don't know about this DSP I don't I
watch it out the walls are covered with
writing quotations from the bone okay
what do we got here it's a toilet what
we got more drugs holy [ __ ]
that man loves Christ well don't we on
just kidding all right let's go oh hey
Matt how you then all right cool I think
I think we're ready to go
not much to see here Oh hold it down yes
I don't know what I feel about it I
guess we gotta keep looking at Jesus no
no looking at Jesus that way yeah
candles are still lit he should be back
soon that makes sense
what is that ro um all right
oh no he doesn't look friendly huh hey I
just met you and this is awkward but I
like your ginseng Nathaniel just the man
we're looking for angels and ministers
of grace defend us
I'm agent Nam and jayden FBI I'd like to
ask you a few questions
as God is my witness I haven't done
anything I'm in relax nobody's accusing
you of anything you just want to talk
all right so what about your job
what do you work in Sanyo you have a job
my sole occupation is praying to the
all-merciful Lord for the salvation of
humanity that sounds fun so what do you
have an alibi
Nathaniel do you remember where you were
last Tuesday at 4:30 p.m. here I was
here I was praying all day oh man your
life seems awesome was there anybody
with you no no I was alone huh well what
about the crucifixes why all the
crucifixes you afraid of something
the hour is nigh and the wrath of God
shall strike men down I'm preparing for
the end of the world death getting what
about the voices Nathaniel
do you still hear the voices we know who
talks to you don't we Nathaniel oh we
both know who talks to you don't be an
[ __ ] DSP to it speak that the devil
what does he say to you boy you know
what he's not like I can't talk about
thanks doc he mustn't talk about it he
orders you to go and find your prey
leave him alone needs more and more what
whatever okay I can go right into you
mustn't mention him you'll bring him
here
he told you to go Carnac in the park you
boy you're my minute you all night long
you wanted them to stop didn't you
Nathaniel I interfere too early
this becomes weird that's not right so
you obeyed them to make them stop you
took that boy with you when you're drown
hey isn't that right oh stop you killed
that didn't you Nathaniel are you gonna
confess you bastard come on man you are
the Antichrist ha ha ha ha ha ha your
father in it how's that again battle he
is the son of Satan he was sent to earth
through the show shed for Christ's sake
shoot psychology you're not gonna kill
the Antichrist with a revolver Nathaniel
he's much too powerful
he attacked Christ my ass get that gun
out of my face
calm down Keep Calm everything is going
to be fine Nathaniel
t Oh sh ed oh you shall know divine
power I I shot him
yep looks like you did
I didn't mean to that can't say I'll
miss him come on let's go son of a [ __ ]
you made me look like an [ __ ]
ah he was gonna shoot him
he was totally gonna shoot him you
didn't have to shoot in his face that's
stupid
come on man I don't want to kids God
it's God - can I lick your nose no just
once please edit blunder nice car bruh
Alex written you swear how they mix all
the new things in this game with our in
all but everything else is seeing Canada
it's glamping your window just snatching
your people up tryna rape you so y'all
need to hide Scott Shelby and you my
hydrogel me hide you why alrighty then
let's go and investigate shall we breath
open open
Oh convenient so that is not a word
don't even worry about it there's a baby
is it Justin
it sounds like em
ah what is this mrs. balls this was bold
series that's her name oh it's too hard
I can't stand it anymore take care of my
baby no watch call everybody hello
wait a minute watch maybe she's still in
the house come on why don't we go wait
what
ah let us in here lissa boles Rose are
you there all chopped you got to do it
harder bruh hahaha come on
that's is gonna hurt tomorrow oh [ __ ]
yeah bro that's a lot of periodo take
her up yeah this is balls
this is balls can you hear me now na
wake up
she's dead bruh wake up
beautiful
she'll lie let's put it down on the bed
yeah how could you kill yourself if you
have it wrong I'm gonna call an
ambulance no I I don't want to go to the
hospital please
okay you got something round here I can
dress this one with yeah I think so okay
okay don't move
I'll be right back hi brothers I'm gonna
end this episode here but I'm not
compared if you enjoyed subscribe you
become a breath today and I'll see you
next episode have you rest